how hard do you work I'm talking about
like the early years I don't know what
the process is now it's the exact same I
do the exact same now as I did when I
was 21 and 1975. you used to you sit I
sit I play with ideas I go this is funny
I want to talk about the stickers on the
back of the minivans wait wait you're
not being specific enough for me in
other words you do a bit I'm gonna pick
one of your bits you went to a Chinese
restaurant and uh you're like I really
admire Chinese people because they're
really sticking to this Chopsticks thing
the line is I like how they're hanging
in there with the Chopsticks right
because they've seen the fork they've
seen the fork we've got it you beat yeah
but they're going now to me this is a
brilliant observation thank you yes now
when you had that observation were you
sitting at a Chinese restaurant and can
you go to a Chinese restaurant and not
sit there and work on material I'm never
not working on material so even even
when you're sitting with your wife
you're sitting with the kids it's
material every second of my existence
I'm thinking could I do something with
that that to me sounds torturous like
you cannot lie so if I came over to your
house and we were hanging out you're
kind of really looking for material not
kind of I'm looking for material that's
being at work 24 hours a day it's
neurotic making jokes is not work it
it's a gift have you ever been in
therapy no so it doesn't bother you that
like when you're with your wife are you
authentically with your wife are you
saying oh no it's Universal and I can
relate to that no I'm not authentically
with her nor am I authentically with you
right now right you are somewhere else
there's material in here yeah I'm
looking for something right now and
guess what there's nothing here oh I can
sit and remember all of this material
what else have I got to do that's your
day you memorize this material Howard
you do it over and over and over you say
to Tiger Woods i i how do you remember
which club to use what what the hell
else is this guy got to do so when
someone says to you oh you have it so
easy you're so naturally funny and blah
blah blah yes you are naturally funny
and you do have that ability to figure
that stuff out but they don't realize
the amount of work that goes into it
it's like going into the gym every day
it's hard you know how you walk in every
day and you go oh geez I gotta do this
again yeah it sounds like a tortured
life and you say it is it is it is but
you know what your blessing in life is
when you find the torture you're
comfortable with
courage it's kids it's work it's work
it's exercise yes it's not eating the
food you want to eat right find the
torture you're comfortable with and
you'll do well do you ever dream of the
day where you could go with your wife to
a Chinese restaurant and sit there and
not think about that the Chopsticks are
ridiculous I shoot myself in the mouth
would you what what fun is life if I'm
not making jokes all but you said it's a
torture also it's a torture I love wow
you really know yourself
I I just I guess I do yeah I guess I do